okay so
maybe we can get started um all right so
today we're looking at chapter three of
the hugging phase course
and this chapter is is kind of like
bringing together
all of the components that we've been
looking at in the first two chapters
so just as a recap in the first chapter
we looked at sort of the concepts around
the transformer
and some concepts around tokenization
and pre-training and in chapter 2 we
started taking a deep dive into
what really happens inside this pipeline
api
that we were using a lot in the first
chapter and trying to really unpack
sort of how to train a model or at least
how to
understand the inputs and outputs of a
model and also the inputs and outputs
for the tokenizer so today we're
actually going to bring this all
together
and we're going to do a couple of things
we're going to
look at the data sets library which is
this very nifty library developed by
hugging face for processing
data sets of more or less any size
and then we're going to train our very
first model using something called the
trainer
and the trainer is an api which
basically wraps
a lot of the complexity around writing
your own training loop
um in pi torch or tensorflow
and then we're going to sort of take it
like we're going to kind of unpack
what's going on in some sense in that
trainer by writing
our own uh training loop in pytorch
and this will be a great excuse to
introduce a very cool library that
sylvan has developed called hugging face
accelerate
and this library is really
designed for doing what's called
distributed training so
how you can kind of speed up your
training when you've got multiple gpus
or potentially even tpus which is what
we'll see today in google collab
and of course if there's any questions
just ask them in the chat at any time
and i'll be pausing at various points to
take
um time to answer them and so
maybe just to start the the kind of
ecosystem
that we kind of have a hugging face at
the moment
roughly revolves around these um sort of
components so we've got the the hub
which we've seen
several times now already and we use the
hub
for both loading models in transformers
loading tokenizers
and also loading data sets um and then
transformers interacts with the data
sets library
as we'll see today as a way of training
our models
and then once the models are trained we
can then push them back to the hub
so that then we can share them with our
colleagues and we can also interact with
them
using some of the widgets that are
developed
by the hugging face team so
with that let's um take a quick look at
the datasets library
so the the datasets library is
a kind of general purpose library for
processing
data sets of more or less any type so
originally
it was specifically for text data sets
for nlp
but since then it's kind of grown into
something that can
handle images audio
and over time we'll have things like
time series and so on
and the main power of this library is
that it
provides a kind of uniform api um
for processing data and at least for me
personally this has been one of the
biggest productivity gains in in my sort
of career as
a data scientist because previously
like i was always having to manipulate
different types of data csv
json text whatever and each time it was
always a little bit idiosyncratic and
you had to write your own sort of custom
like functions for dealing with all
these data types and the datasets
library provides
a very simple api where you can
basically load a data set more or less
in one line of code
and then you can process it using
something called the map function which
we'll discuss in more detail
today and more or less with with this
map function
um you can kind of do extremely
like fast and crazy processing even on
monster data sets that are like you know
a terabyte in size
you can actually process this on your
laptop because this
does a very clever kind of lazy loading
of memory
using something called apache arrow okay
so let me just have a quick look great
cool so maybe what we can do is we can
start
by looking at this introductory video on
the datasets library
so i'm going to play this and
please let me know if you can't hear it
the urging face datasets library a quick
overview
the arcing fest datasets library is a
library that provides an api to quickly
download many public data sets
and preprocess them in this video we'll
explore how to do that
the downloading part is easy with the
load dataset function
you can directly download and cache a
dataset from its identifier on the
datasetup
here we fetch the armorpc dataset from
the glue benchmark
which is a set containing pairs of
sentences where the task is to determine
the paraphrases
the object returned by the load dataset
function is a dataset dict
which is a sort of dictionary containing
each split of our dataset
access each split by indexing with its
name
this split is then an instance of the
dataset class
with columns here sentence 1 sentence 2
label and idx and rows
you can access a given element by its
index
the amazing thing about the aging phase
datasets library is that everything is
saved to disk
using upper shower which means that even
if your data set is huge
you won't get out of ram only the
elements you request
are loaded in memory accessing a slice
of your data set
is as easy as one element the result is
then a dictionary with lists of values
for each case
here the list of labels the list of
first sentences and the list of second
sentences
the features attribute of a data set
gives us more information about its
columns
in particular we can see here it gives
us the correspondence between the
integers
and names for the labels zero stands for
not equivalent
and one for equivalent to preprocess all
the elements of our dataset
we need to tokenize them have a look at
the video preprocessed sentence pairs
for a refresher
but you just have to send the two
sentences to the tokenizer
with some additional keyword arguments
here we indicate a maximum length of 128
and pad inputs shorter than its length
truncate inputs that are longer we put
all of this in the tokenize function
that we can directly apply to all the
splits in our data set
with the map method as long as the
function returns a dictionary-like
object
the map method will add new columns as
needed or update
existing ones to speed up pre-processing
and take advantage of the fact our
tokenizer is backed by rust
thanks to the in-phase tokenizers
library we can process several elements
at the same time in our tokenize
function
using the patch equal to argument since
the tokenizer can handle list of first
sentences list of second sentences
the tokenized function does not need to
change for this
you can also use primary processing with
the map method check out its
documentation
linked below once this is done
we're almost ready for training we just
remove the columns we don't need anymore
with the remove columns method rename
label to labels
since the models from the aging phase
transformers library expect that
and set the output format to the desired
backend torch
tensorflow on input if needed
we can also generate a short sample of a
data set using the select method
great so that was a
whirlwind tour of the dallas library are
there any questions at this stage
before we dive into some code
okay so feel free to post them in the
chat
as they come so
one thing i just want to mention that
might be useful so on the
hugging face hub we have
looked at the models hub
in the last lesson and today we're going
to kind of be looking a lot more closely
at the data sets
and there was a question last week about
sort of how do you figure out like a
good
choice of model for say multi-class
versus multi-label
and at the time we sort of realized that
there's no sort of easy way of like
filtering
these types of models but it turns out
that for data sets
there is a little bit better search for
this so
for example if i'm working on a new
project
one of the fastest ways to get results
early
is to basically build a sort of baseline
or a prototype
using some public data this is often
much cheaper and faster than
waiting for you know to get permission
to access data
in your company or waiting for some
domain experts to help you with the
labeling
and so for example if we were looking at
like maybe like a multi-class thing
maybe i would pick say text
classification
and then there are other tags here that
i can sort of filter by so
just in case i was interested in
question answering i could select that
and then inside text classification
there are a set of sub tasks that we can
look at
so for example here i can maybe select
multi-label classification
and then this will return a range of
data sets
which are candidates for the multi-label
case
so perhaps i'm doing something about
fake news
then i can look at this
data set called fake news english and
vice versa
so the the data sets hub is a great way
of like bootstrapping
your machine learning projects at work
and i've found this
is a a great way also of finding some
interesting data sets that maybe go
beyond the standard ones that you often
see in nlp
so almost everyone uses imdb movie
reviews
to show their their training but there's
a lot of extra things here that are
quite interesting and challenging
because many of these are community
provided
and just a side note if you have an
interesting data set
that you think would be valuable to the
community
you can either contribute it directly to
the data sets repository
and so inside the data sets repository
we have a data sets
folder which has all of these hundreds
of data sets
that are basically reviewed and curated
by the hugging case team
so you can open a pull request and
there's instructions in the
documentation on how to how to do this
or if you wish to provide a community
data set which is something that
more or less you don't have to integrate
into the library directly
you can also do that and there are some
links in the documentation on how to
basically submit data sets to the hub
so let's have a look if there's any
questions none so far
great so maybe omar can put some links
to that community
versus canonical datasets
okay so there's a question from srmsuma
dataset's library looks very specific to
nlp
i couldn't find many datasets related to
vision is there a limitation to host
vision related data
so the short answer is no there isn't a
limitation in the library it's just that
we haven't devoted a lot of effort to
integrating vision data sets
and if you have some ideas of vision
data sets you would like to add
by all means feel free to either open a
pr
in the datasets library or
just reach out in the forums basically
at the moment we have if i look here um
let's see can i find vision
um do we have a tag for vision
let's have a look so i don't think we
have a
tag for vision yet um but
i i know that we have um let's see i
think we have cipher
oh we don't have c5 maybe mnist
interesting i was fairly sure we had
these data sets
okay so so maybe some of these vision
data sets are not yet
passed because this okay
yeah good okay so we have cfr 10 c5 100
and these data sets you can use using
the dices library
and there's also others for earth i
think i'm pretty sure emnest is here so
there's fashion amnesty mnus and so on
so great question um
so i think i can chuck the link in the
chat
here so this will this is the link to
mnist
um let's put this here
cool so i hope that answers your
question srm super
um okay so now
maybe what we can do to start with is
let's have a sort of look at the
um colab for the datasets library so we
kind of get our hands dirty with this
so as usual the first thing i want to do
is install
data sets and transformers and i'm going
to use the
capture magic command to capture all the
pip junk that comes out
so once this will take a few minutes um
and remember that the the basic process
um
in in the sort of transformers workflow
is
we um first we need a tokenizer to
convert our text
our raw text into input ids
and then we need a model to process
those input ids and convert them into
numerical outputs that we can you know
build predictions on so basically here
um i'm just uh instantiating
a tokenizer and a model so this is going
to be
uh bert base encased and this model is
an
auto model for sequence classification
so it's a text
classification head that we're adding on
top of the pre-trained model
and this is just a little code snippet
that shows
an example of how to process
basically the the raw sequences convert
them into
input ids and then pass this and the
labels
through the uh through the model okay
but
we saw that last week so um should we
clear the thing that
is more interesting for us today is to
start looking at the data sets i read so
the the first thing or the most common
thing you're going to
encounter is the load data set function
and if we just have a look at this load
helps
load data set function
you can see that it has a lot of
different arguments that you can provide
the most common ones that i use are the
path
which is essentially the name of the
data set this is what you will see for
example
on the hub so in this case we have glue
but it could be mnist it could be
whatever
and many data sets on the hub they often
have
configurations which are like sort of
like subsets
so for example blue is a benchmark which
has many different
tasks and each task has a name so here
we have the microsoft
paraphrase comprehension
task and so if you want to access a
subtask
or a subset in a given data set you use
this name
argument and then the other one that
we'll see that is really common is to
specify the split
so a lot of the time by or by default
it will return all the splits that are
defined in the
in the library so here we're getting a
train validation and test split
but sometimes you just want the train
split and so you can specify those
explicitly and i'll show you how
okay so so now when we do load data set
we get a data sets
object and there are two sort of
types of objects you'll typically see so
the most common one you'll get
at the start is something called a data
set dict
and this is you can think of it as
basically a dictionary
where the keys are just a string that
correspond to the split
and the values are something called a
dataset
object so let's just have a look at one
of these examples
here so if i index into
the train key or the trains set
i'm going to get now a dataset object
and if i look at the first element
in that dataset object i've got an id
i've got a label
and i've got the two sentences that i
need to figure out
if one is a paraphrase of the other or
not so in this case
we can see that the first sentence says
amrazi accused his brother whom he
called the witness of deliberately
distorting his evidence
and the second sentence says referring
to him as only the witness
and rosie accused his brother of
deliberately discerning the evidence
so that's a pretty good example of the
second sentence being a
or maybe the first one being a
paraphrase of the second one so it's a
bit shorter and it captures the same
information
and we can see that the label here is
one which as a guess is probably
indicating that that's true
it is a paraphrase okay so just to like
unpack a little bit
this um this data set dict versus data
set thing so
because this was a bit confusing to me
the first time i saw this so we know
that
the raw data sets are given by this
dataset dict
object and this dataset dict object has
these keys right
so we have train validation and
test set and if we look at just like a
normal sort of python dictionary if we
look at the values
then we get now a dictionary or we get a
list of of the different values
so just think of dataset dict as a
dictionary which maps
keys or splits to data sets and the
thing that you do
nearly all of your work or your heavy
work on
are actually the data set objects so if
we look at a data set object
so this raw train data set
this data set object has a large number
of operations that we can do
and we're going to see some of them
today so we can add columns
we can do filtering we can
[Music]
load um from different formats
we can extract some information about
the data
so maybe let's have a look at that if we
look at the the info attribute of a data
set
this will often tell us uh maybe we can
print it
this will okay that's like that so this
will tell us a bit of a description
about the data set itself
and there's a bunch of uh information
about
the data types and so on um so
yeah basically just remember that data
set is the thing that we're going to be
doing most of our work on and data set
dict is just a way of
collecting all the splits together so
let's just see if there's any questions
none so far okay good
so um one of the important
aspects of a data set is that it has
essentially types so one of the things
that you may have experienced
in your work is that most of the data
you deal with is very like messy or
maybe it has
like it's like a csv file and you've got
a mix of strings and numbers and so
forth
and what the datasets library does is it
defines
very explicitly what the types should be
for every column
in the data set and so this is very
useful because it allows you to
patch errors earlier and also to do some
very fast processing
so if you look at the features attribute
of a data set
what you'll get is a dictionary which
shows you
essentially the column name as a key and
then the data type
for that column and so we can see here
that indeed sentence one is a string
so we get something called a value type
and here it specifies a string but the
other one that's kind of interesting
is maybe the label so here the label
column
it's not just an integer i mean it could
be an integer but datasets provides
something called a class label
type and this class label type contains
information
about the number of classes that we have
or the number of unique
labels that we have what the names of
those labels are
and those are the more basically the two
things that you you need to know
is just um the names and the number of
classes
and then we can see that for example the
id is just got a data type of um
integer 32 and so one of the things you
can do with these features
so one thing that's like kind of nice if
we so features is just a dictionary so
we can
access the values by
key so if we get the label this is going
to give us this
this class label type and this class
label type has a couple of handy
functions so one function that i often
use a lot
is how do i convert my numerical
features
so label one into something that i is
like human readable
so what i can do is there's an int to
string function
and if i put label one here
it should tell me indeed that that
corresponds to equivalent which means
that one sentence
is a paraphrase of the other and just as
a sanity check if we do zero
then it should be the same for not
equivalent and so
this um this class label feature
has some documentation on the hub with
other functions you can look at but i
find this is quite a powerful way of
quickly switching between labels that
are numbers and labels that are strings
so that you can
understand um you know what's in your
data set
so let's have a look are there any
questions okay so there's a question
from
i am homes is there a way to benefit
from the convenience of the dataset
library
but use a data set that might be private
for example customer data
yes that's a great question and the
answer is yes you can
so there are so previously before i
joined huggingface i was working for a
telecom company
and everything was like completely
closed off in
you know on premise we couldn't use
hugging face hub
so i actually had to solve this problem
so the way you could do this
or the way i used to do this most
frequently is i would actually use
pandas so i would say input pandas as pd
and then i would create my data frame so
let's suppose i'm going to just make a
dummy data frame so let's say
i have oops
my data frame as follows and i'm going
to say
okay let's call this
i know text then i'm going to put
hello world and then maybe another
element
um today
okay and then i'll add another column
which is maybe the let's say the label
and then maybe this is going to be
positive positive
so this is this is a super simple data
frame but this is something that i would
load
locally and of course pandas is amazing
for data processing but if you want to
use the the data sets functionality what
you can do
is create your own data set your own
custom data set
so from data sets you can import
the data set object itself and then what
we can do
is we can create a data set
from um the let's see so i think it's
from
is it from pandas i think um
and then this should fingers crossed
create now
a dataset object which has
the features of text and label has two
rows
and if we now for example look at all
the elements we can see that indeed
we've now got our own
custom data set so
this is more or less how i how i used to
work 90
of the time um i hope that answers your
question i'm homes there are other ways
of loading data you can load it
from csv you can load it from jason
and i think that more or less covers
most
most of the use cases the only time
things get a little bit painful
is if you're dealing with very large
data sets you know things that maybe
don't fit into
pandas data frame but there's a
streaming
functionality that has just been
implemented into the datasets library
and so yeah i think basically you can
cover almost all
use cases this way okay cool
so
[Music]
what we've just done so far is we've uh
just loaded our raw
data set um and the thing that
um we would like to do right is we'd
like to tokenize this
so what we've been doing um in all of
the
lessons so far is we've basically been
tokenizing
kind of like string by string or like
maybe a list of strings
so if we look at this example here then
when we do the tokenization
you can see that tokenizing the first
[Music]
sentence column is giving us now
a list of input ids so we have now
basically a set of input ids well let's
just have a look at these guys
um so yeah we've got a big list of input
ids corresponding to the first sentence
and also to the second sentence
and remember that these ids is what are
what we used
um to feed into the transformer
these are the things that go into the
embedding layer and then into the
transformer stack and at the end we get
something like budgets we can make
predictions with okay
so um that's the stuff we've been doing
all the time
and you can also as i think we may have
seen you can convert
your ids back to tokens using the
convert ids to tokens
but the thing that is is like maybe
most interesting or most common is is
how do you basically tokenize the whole
data set
and the the most common way to do this
is to define a function
you can call it whatever you want here
it's called tokenized function
and what this function will do is it
will operate on every row
of the data set and apply whatever you
define
the operation to be in that function
so once you've defined your function you
can then
apply a map onto your data set
and then this will automatically
tokenize every single row
in your data set so we've got all the
raw strings sentence one sentence two
and it's converted them automatically
into input ids
and also this attention mask that we saw
last
last week where we needed to figure out
how to um
sort of disable the padding tokens from
the attention mechanism
so this is a very powerful way of kind
of
in just more or less one or two lines of
code automatically tokenizing every
single example in your data set
and it's very fast it can be it can be
basically multi-processed and it can
also be run in a batch way on a gpu to
be even faster
um but maybe let's just like sort of
look at a
sort of very simple example just to
break down what's going on here
so let's suppose i wanted to do
something which is quite common
um maybe adding a a column now there are
faster ways of doing this in data sets
but i'm going to show you how we could
do this with
with a function so let's um add a column
and what this column should expect is an
example
or let's just maybe even make easier
it's a row it's a row in our data set
and the main thing that this
function needs to return is it has to
return a dictionary
and the reason for that is if you look
at
one of our examples from the
from the training set you can see that
it's kind of like a dictionary right
we've got
keys for the column name and value for
the actual
element or you know the element and
that's a cell if it was a table
so what we need to do is we need to
return
strange it seems that collab does too
okay so we need to return a dictionary
and let's just i'm going to make
something up i'm going to say this is a
new column
and i'm going to just make all the value
of my new column
be just a word hello okay
and if we do this then if i take my raw
data sets
well let's just take maybe the raw
training data set just to keep it simple
then when we apply map we just need to
feed it this function
and it will then automatically
create a new column
and just add it to our raw data set now
one thing you should be aware of is that
this operation
is not in place so if you're familiar
with pandas
there's often operations that are in
place which means you just run this line
and then it kind of
changes the state of the object um in
data sets
um most if not all operations are out of
place
and so what this would mean is that if
you wanted to actually have that column
stored in your memory you would create
you know data set with say
extra column or new column and you would
then do
you know that equals the map and then
when you look at
this you now see that we have
a new column with hello so that's been
now
sort of stored in the memory of this new
dataset object okay so
just to recap need a function and the
function has to always return a
dictionary
where the key is the name of the column
and
the value is the value you want
for that uh row
cool so let's take a small thing let's
see um
[Music]
i am homes is asking please could you
explain
what the attention mask does again ah
okay great very good question
so um let's have a look at this example
here
so in this um example we've got
two sentences and we can see that
this is maybe not a good example maybe
let's add some padding
[Music]
okay actually what i need to do to show
you an example
is i'm going to
yeah i'm going to do this so i'm going
to
i'm going to apply truncation in my
function and i'm going to add some
padding
and then this is just to show you
what we're talking about here okay so
here i've just
tokenized the raw data sets and i've got
this tokenized datasets
object and let's
get the first element which hopefully
will show us
okay this is a bit of a messy one
okay but let me just try to summarize so
um
remember in the last uh chapter we
looked at this concept of padding
and the reason we had to do padding is
that all the operations that we do
inside the transformer are basically
matrix multiplication
and when you do matrix multiplication
you want to make sure that
the matrices you're operating on are
more or less
square so if i have for example one
sentence
and i represent this as a vector then
in order to compare one sentence to
another sentence
it helps if those arrays or those
vectors
have the same size and so padding is a
technique
where you can basically in the simplest
case
look at the longest sentence in your
batch and then just
put a zero at the end of every other
sentence
which basically pads out to the length
of the longest one
and then this will guarantee that your
sentence
or your batch has all vectors of the
same size and then when you stack them
together you've now got something that's
rectangular
now that's padding and more or less we
do it for
just computational reasons but the
problem
that it introduces is that the attention
mechanism
you may remember from from one of the
early chapters
it basically takes an embedding so these
numerical representations that we have
of of the sequence
and it then updates them to create
something called a contextualized
embedding
and these contextualized embeddings um
essentially contain for every token in
that sequence
they contain information that relates
the sort of meaning of that token
relative to the whole sequence
so an example would be if i have a
sentence like
um i know time flies like an arrow then
flies is a verb in that case
but if i have another sentence which is
like fruit flies like a banana
then flies is an insect and so the
attention mechanism allows us to
distinguish these two cases because the
contextualized embedding that represents
flies
is different in those two cases and it
uses the whole sequence
to develop that that representation
now because attention operates on every
single token
in the sequence um it also operates on
padding tokens
and this would be like a bit of a
problem because these padding tokens are
like these artificial
things we injected just to make sure all
the matrices are square
and so the attention mask is a way of
saying to the intention mechanism pay no
attention
to the padding tokens and what an
attention mask will look like
here it will have a bunch of ones
so these will be all the tokens at the
start of the sequence
that are just the the things we want to
develop
contextualizing bettings for and then at
some point
you will hit the the start of the
padding sequence
so you've got all your words and now
you're just adding zeros to your
token embeddings and here the attention
mask will then switch to a zero
and that will when it goes through the
attention layer it will just disable
attention
computations on that
so i hope that explains your question
iron homes it was a bit of a long-winded
one
and so one's for all the input ids
correct exactly right yep so
all the input ids which are not zero or
generally not zero it will be a one and
then it will be zero for all the input
ids that are zero so we can have a look
here
all the input ids are non-zero and now
we've got the padding
ids okay great so there's another
question which is from resh
meshech can we do the reverse of a map
function
um let me think if i understand what you
mean
so
so what kind of example would you have
in mind
resh
i'm not sure i understand the question
but maybe you can write it in the chat
and then i'll come back to it in a bit
okay so we've seen how to
do tokenization across the whole data
set using the map function
and the um i
think that's more or less the main thing
in this collab so i'm just going to
delete this um and
the other thing um uh that is worth
pointing out is there's kind of two ways
you can do padding
so one way is to explicitly
define the padding in the tokenization
step so what you do is you say
padding true or however you wish to
implement it
and then when you do tokenization with
the map function it will automatically
pad
all the sequences according to how you
defined it
now the drawback with this is that when
you do training
maybe your padding for example here
picked the longest
sentence in the whole data set and then
padded everything out to the thing in
the whole data set
but when we do training what we're
really doing is we're doing training on
batches
and so one thing that is quite common is
to do something called
dynamic padding which we'll see shortly
which is a way of basically
sort of adding the padding tokens on the
fly and this lets us do computations
much more efficiently
so i think let's take a look at that
video now
so let's have a look at how we can do
padding on the fly
what is dynamic padding
in the batching inputs together video we
have seen that to be able to group
inputs of different lengths
in the same batch we need to add padding
tokens to all the short inputs
until they're all of the same lengths
here for instance
the longest sentence is the third one
and we need to add
five two or seven pad tokens to the
other sentences
to have four sentences of the same
length
when dealing with the word data set
there are various padding strategies we
can apply
the most obvious one is to pad all the
elements of the data set to the same
length
the length of the longest sample this
will then give us patches that all have
the same shape
determined by the maximum sequence
length the downside is that batch is
composed from short sentences
will have a lot of padding tokens which
will introduce more computations
in the model we ultimately don't need
to avoid this another strategy is to pad
the elements
when we batch them together to the
longest sentence inside the batch
this way batches composed of short
inputs will be smaller than the batch
containing the longest sentence in the
data set
this will lead some nice speed up on cpu
and gpu
the downside is that all batches will
then have different shapes
which slows down things on accelerators
like tpus
let's see how to apply both strategies
in practice
we have actually seen how to apply fixed
padding in the data sets of a view video
when we preprocess the armor pc data set
after loading the data set on tokenizer
we apply the tokenization to all the
data set with padding
and location to make all samples of
length 128
as a result if we pass this data set to
a pytorch data loader
we get patches of shape patch size year
by 128 to apply dynamic padding we must
defer the padding to the patch
preparation
so we remove that part from our tokenize
function
we still leave the truncation part so
that inputs that are bigger than the
maximum flanks
accepted by the model usually 512
get truncated to that length then we
paddle some posts dynamically by using a
data collector
both classes in the transformers library
are responsible for applying all the
final pre-processing needed before
forming a batch
here the decollator with padding will
pass the sample so the maximum length
inside the batch of sentences
we pass it to the pytorch data loader as
a collate function
then observe that the batches generated
at various lengths
all way below the 128 from before
dynamic batching will almost always be
faster on cpus and gpus
so you should apply it if you can
remember to switch back to fixed padding
however
if you run your training script on tpus
or need batches of fixed chips
okay so that was a nice explanation of
dynamic padding so just to summarize
um if i have a data set with say a
thousand examples
and let's suppose that one example is
just way longer than all the others
maybe there's an error or something so
if i just did
my tokenization um
on this um data set as we just did
before in the collab
and we just pad to the maximum length of
the longest example
then all the samples will get pushed out
to this very long one and so we'll have
a lot of zeros everywhere that we have
to then do computations on which are
slower
so the alternative is that since we do
most of our training in terms of batches
that we just pad
at the batch level so instead of padding
for the whole data
set we just look at the elements in a
batch and we pad
to the longest for example element in
that batch or the longest example in
that patch
and what this will do is it will then
require less computation so we faster
but the downside is sylvan explained is
that each batch will have different
sizes
so we're going to have um you know maybe
in one batch
the the sentence is only 10 tokens long
for the longest one so everything is 10
tokens long
maybe the second batch is 30 and so on
so
in the transformers library we have what
are called data collaters
and these data collaters are basically
functions
that allow us to kind of cleverly
package together all these different
size batches in a way that we can then
do
training efficiently
so let's maybe look at some questions
and then just revisit this uh collate
data collater
stuff so there's a question from
let's see
okay so we've got a question from uns
which says hi
there's a limited label data sets that
aren't english
would it make sense to machine translate
a data set to a certain language or
domain specific genre to fine tune on
yes that's a very good question
and generally highly recommended
so a good example of this
is there's a data set called mlqa
and this is a multilingual question
answering data set
and the authors of this data set
basically
translated the squad data set which is
in english
into several languages so i think they
have german
spanish hindi vietnamese simplified
chinese
so this is one way of creating data
in your domain or your language which
you can then build models on the only
drawback
is that it's often being known that if
you're training like very large
transformer models
they can learn somehow that
there's a translation that's been made
and they'll they'll take shortcuts
to get good performance so in the end
the model that you get on your
translated text
it may be good just in the translated
context but if you then deploy this with
real human interactions
then this could be sort of out of domain
and maybe the model has only really
learned how to
detect that it was translated and not
how to actually solve the task you care
about
so um you have to be a bit careful with
this but it's something that um
is is worth trying and it's something
i've used as well
in switzerland where i live there are
four national languages plus
english and so most of the time you
don't
have data in english it comes in italian
or french and so you need to do some of
this translation
tricks um and one thing that came out
recently which is
i think quite cool is um facebook
released a model
called m2m 100
and this model is um a translation model
so it's a it's a sequence or it's an
encoder decoder
transformer that we saw in chapter one
and it can do basically
translations across 100 different
languages
so you imagine you've got basically a
hundred by 100 matrix
of all languages and for every single
pair you can do a translation
and so this gives you 9 900
pairs you can translate across and it's
a very good model
so if you're looking to do translation i
would recommend using this
if if your language is in the 100 that
they cover
um okay and then maybe to revisit
resha's question
um how could you revert the column that
was created before in the map
okay now i understand what you're asking
so
the question is let's suppose we've
added
this column and we've now got
a data set with a new column which says
hello
um i'll show you the specific one for
this example is like
if i want to delete the column then what
i can do
is i can remove columns
and then here i just need to provide a
list of column names
so i could provide new column
and then this will delete
the new column and recover back the
original
data set that we had that more or less i
think would cover
most of the cases that you want to undo
the map operation
um the only time it won't really work is
if you then do other things to your data
set maybe you
change the the content of these original
columns and then
you know undoing that isn't easily done
okay and now we have another question by
srm
zuma which is why is dynamic padding
slow on tpus
compared to gpus is there any intuition
behind this
okay so this is testing my uh very
limited tpu knowledge
um but my understanding uh
very limited understanding is that um
it's a sort of fundamentally different
architecture
for basically doing a numerical
or numerical algebra linear algebra or
algebraic equations
multiplications of matrices and i think
it's simply just due to the way that the
chips are designed
that they are much more efficient if
everything
is a fixed uh sized matrix and you're
not trying to do this like
shuffling of data to to do the collation
but omar who's in the chat as hakalama
he um he used to work at google so he
can maybe
provide a much better answer in the chat
um so yeah this is uh
it's a very good question i i would also
really like to know a detailed answer so
that'll be cool
okay so um what i wanted to do uh before
we start training the model is just have
a quick look at this
um what this data collation is doing
so in transformers there are different
data collaters
to basically handle this dynamic padding
and
the one that most of the time we use is
data collateral with padding
and what this will do is
let's see can i see it yeah if i get a
few samples from my data set
what i've got here in my samples
is just a list of you know the tokenized
inputs and they've got the
the same length for the input ids so
they've been uh that's probably because
i added padding
so let me get rid of padding here sorry
so i'm just going to re-tokenize my data
without the padding in the tokenizer um
because we want to do dynamic padding
and one thing that's very cool i didn't
really mention is that in data sets
all the operations that you do are
cached so they're basically stored as
arrow tables in
in your in your hard drive and so then
when you want to
reprocess it basically checks have i
done this computation before and if it
does it will just load the cached
version
and that's extremely fast so you can see
that you know it took like a second
and this is very cool if you've done
something that you know you process like
a million examples and then
you restart the notebook you don't have
to wait again to reprocess them the
cache will just
do that instantaneously
okay good so so now i've got um i've
tokenized my data
i have no padding so all the examples
are of different lengths
and so what the data collater will do
when i pass it through these samples
is it will automatically resize
in that batch all the samples to the
longest
length in that batch so you can see here
that the longest example has 67 tokens
and so what it's done now is it's
created
tensors each of which
have essentially 67 columns
you know for each of the longest tokens
and some of those will have padding
and that's what the data collater has
done for us and then when we do training
it will do all of that for us on the fly
um yeah exactly so the question that
srmsum is asking about about the tpus is
that square matrices are what gpu's like
as well yes that's true so
i if i'm not mistaken the the tpu
context is to do with this
distinction of whether you do dynamic
padding or not
and with dynamic padding we are
kind of creating square matrices
on a batch level but we're also moving
data around
so we're having to sort of kind of
dynamically
create data on the fly different shapes
and my suspicion is that's the thing
that maybe slows it down but
it's a great question and i should look
at the answer
at some point
cool so it's um you've asked a very good
question that stumped
um the two guys in the in the course
they're great thanks
okay cool so um that's
more or less data sets tokenization um
let's now take a look at training
so what we're going to do
is look at the trainer api so
launch the video
the trainer api the transformers library
provides a trainer api
that allows you to easily fine-tune
transformers models on your data set
the trainer class secure data sets your
model
as well as the training ip parameters
and can perform the training on any kind
of setup
cpu gpu multiple gpus tpus you can also
compute the predictions on any data set
and if you provided metrics evaluate
your model on any dataset
you can also undo final data processing
such as dynamic padding
as long as you provide the tokenizer or
a given data collater
we'll try this api in the mrpc data set
since it's relatively small and easy to
pre-process
as we saw in the datasets overview video
very so we can preprocess it
we do not apply padding during the
preprocessing as we will use dynamic
padding without data collector with
padding
note that we don't do the final steps of
renaming removing columns
or set the format to torch tensors the
trainer will do all of this
automatically for us
by analyzing the model's signature
the last step before creating the
trainer are to define our model
and some training upper parameters we
saw to do the first in the model api
video
for the second we use the training
argument class
it only takes a path to a folder where
results and checkpoints will be saved
but you can also customize all the other
parameters that your trainer will use
learning rate number of training epochs
etc
it's been very easy to create a trainer
on launcher training
this should display a progress bar and
after a few minutes
if you're running on a gpu you should
have the training finished
the result will be rather anticlimactic
however as you will only get a training
loss
which doesn't really tell you anything
about how well your model is performing
this is because we didn't specify any
metric for the evaluation
to get those metrics we'll first cover
the predictions on the wall evaluation
set using the predict method
it returns a name to poll with three
fields prediction
which contains the model predictions
label ids which contains the labels if
you data set at them
and matrix which is empty here we're
trying to do that
the predictions are the logics of the
models for all the sentences in the data
set
so an empire array of shape 408 by two
to match them with our labels we need to
take the maximum logic for each
prediction
to know which of the two classes was
predicted
we do this with the rmax function then
we can use a matrix from the datasets
library
it can be loaded as easily as a dataset
with the loadmetric function
and it returns the evaluation metric
used for the data set
we can see our model did learn something
as it is 85.7 percent accurate
to monitor the evaluation matrix during
training we need to define a compute
metric function
that does the same step as before it
takes a name to pull with predictions
and labels
and must return a dictionary of the
matrix we want to keep track of
by passing the epoch evaluation strategy
to our training arguments
we tell the trainer to evaluate at the
end of every epoch
launching a training inside a notebook
will then display a progress bar
and complete the table you see here as
you pass every epoch
okay so that was a lot of information if
you've never seen the trainer
it might have been too many things at
once so what we're going to do
is kind of walk through this together
and then hopefully into this you'll then
have all the tools you need
to start training your own models and
solving
your own problems so
in google collab there are different run
times available
so by default most of the time it's like
a cpu so there's no
acceleration and so what you need to do
is hit runtime
select the runtime type and for this
notebook we're going to use a gpu
later we'll see how to use a tpu so then
we save this and now this is going to
launch
in google colab
sort of a machine that has a gpu in the
in the back end
and one thing you can do
to check you know what kind of gpu
you're running
is to do nvidia smi
and let's see what we get if it wakes up
so here we've got a tesla kd so these
are
most of the time um uh the sort of
default uh gpu you get
they're not super great um but if you
look online uh you can often find um
[Music]
there's there's people who have saved
the state of things like p100
collabs and then you can just use them
and then they're very fast
and of course if you reset the run time
so this is sometimes a hack if i'm
trying to get a better gpu you can do
factory reset
and then this will just wipe the whole
back end
and hopefully should now still be a gpu
yep
and maybe we'll get something a little
bit different to a k
let's see what we get
okay i'm still stuck with a kd but
sometimes if you're lucky it will give
you a p 100 or even
a tesla okay
so we've got our um our gpu backed
collab now so again we do the same thing
we install our dependencies
and um what we're going to what we have
here in this code is just
the same things we did before so we load
a data set
and then we define a tokenizer from a
checkpoint so we're using bert base
encased
we have our tokenize function
and what this tokenized function is
doing is it's taking the two sentences
remember that this data set is about
trying to predict whether one sentence
is a paraphrase of another
so we pass both sentences to the
tokenizer
we use truncation as true so that
if um one of the sentences is longer
than the
maximum sequence length of bert which is
512 tokens it will just truncate it to
512.
and then we tokenize everything and we
define this data collater so we can do
dynamic padding
so i'm just going to run that
and it should be pretty fast
okay so so while that's running let's uh
start by looking at
um this training arguments this is the
first thing that you
encounter with the trainer so training
arguments you can think of it as just
like a config it's basically
a class where you can define various
uh hyper parameters for training
and the only thing you need to specify
is an output directory where all the
information from the training will be
will be stored
or if you save the model this is where
it will go so if we look at training
arguments
we can see that let's see can we see
through here
you can see that um we have this output
directory
um and then there's a huge range of
things like really a lot you can specify
the learning rate
you can specify the parameters of the
optimizer
you can define the optimizer you can
define callbacks kind of like fast ai
which is no surprise because sylvan
developed the trainer and these
callbacks allow you to control
training in clever ways like early
stopping and things like this
um so i won't go through all of this but
there's basically a large number of
parameters you can set and you can find
that in the documentation
for the trainer um and
it comes with some pretty good defaults
so most of the time it will just work
out of the box
so now we need to load a model and
we're specifying two labels because
we've got just two classes
is it is it a paraphrase or not and
again it's a
sequence classification model because
we're doing text classification
and then comes the
the next pit which is you know maybe the
more complicated part
so we need to instantiate a trainer so
a trainer more or less at minimum
needs a few things it needs a model so
this is the model that we're going to
train
it needs training arguments these are
the things that define how the training
will operate
and it needs one of a few data sets
so it needs either a training data set
or
an evaluation data set or a test set
and you can have one and none of the
others but it needs at least one thing
it
basically needs at least one data set
generally that you want to train on
you can instantiate it without it but
generally you want to specify one
so here we're passing the tokenized data
and that's important
you don't want to pass the raw data to
your
trainer because it will feed it to the
model and then the model will go i don't
know what you're
doing or what i should do with these
strings and the other two things that
are kind of interesting
is passing a data collater
and a tokenizer so providing these two
arguments will do dynamic padding which
will be faster for training
and the way it works is you say hey give
me a collater and there are different
types of data later but the
one we're using is the most common one
and it also needs tokenizer so it's
basically the way the data collater
works is it kind of combines the
tokenizer with the batching
to work out how to arrange the
inputs and so by providing these two
arguments we will then get some speed up
in training
and so this will instantiate the trainer
and let's see if it works
crossed okay good um so one thing that i
usually do before i launch
uh training is i just do like a sanity
check
that i can run the evaluate function
because a lot of the time what happens
is when you run
trainer.train you will train for some
number of steps
and then you will evaluate you know
maybe at the end of an epoch that's kind
of like one of the default strategies
um but then you know if your evaluation
um maybe your metrics are not
implemented correctly or whatever if
your evaluation fails
then you're gonna fail after waiting for
a whole training
of one epoch and that's like really
annoying so a sort of sanity check that
i do is just to make sure that i can run
evaluate and if that works then i'm
relatively confident that
the training run will work and what you
can see
that this evaluation has done is it's
given us some information about the
number of examples in the
in the validation set and it's provided
with a value of the loss
and then some kind of runtime metrics
sort of how performant is this at
processing batches
and so obviously this is a random model
at the moment we've just initialized
burt as a backbone and just stacked on
like
a linear layer with random weights so
this is kind of a garbage loss so the
goal will be
after training for this to be going down
cool so i'm going to now run the
training and
this takes a few minutes so while it's
running we'll then watch
the accelerate video which will show us
how to um well maybe not maybe i'll just
run this and then
see if there's any questions
okay so
dk crazydiv asks we're using bert bass
and cased
and the article mentions wordpiece for
bert but we pip installed
transformer sentence piece are we using
it here
if i were to reverse engineer how would
i programmatically get from checkpoint
and figure out which tokenizer that's a
great question
so the question we have
is why are we doing pip install
transformers
sentence piece um so this is an
an optional dependency which is a
different tokenization
algorithm that is used by models like
xlm roberta and it's listed as an
optional dependency because it's a bit
heavy
so if you don't want to use any models
that don't
require sentence piece for the
tokenization you can just leave it and
it will work
so for example if we just did pip
install with transformers
we will get word piece for free it will
come
part of it but if we want to use these
other models we have to
define explicitly the sentence piece
dependency
so that's like maybe clarifies the first
part of the question
um we're always using wordpiece with
bert and we only install sentence p's
for the models when we need it
and the reason we have it in the course
is because there are some
cases later in in the future parts where
we're going to be using the sentence
piece tokenizer and so
it's just useful if we just always have
access to it
okay so um if i were to reverse engineer
how would i programmatically get from
checkpoint
to figuring out which tokenizer to use
okay
so maybe we can
um i'll answer this in two ways so
the the the simplest way is the
following um in
transformers we have um
an auto model um
uh class uh for different types of
models so this auto model will just do
the
encoding and we also have auto tokenizer
and oops
input and
these classes they do this some pairing
so
if i take auto
tokenizer from pre-trained
and i put bert base
uncased it will
automatically assign the
tokenizer that was associated with that
checkpoint
and then load it into my into my
tokenization of my tokenizer object
and similarly if i do auto
model from pre-trained
and i do the same
checkpoint it will automatically figure
out that for that checkpoint i need
these set of weights
so the the most important thing that you
need to know
is just to make sure that you use the
same checkpoint
for both the tokenizer and the model
when you do the from pre-trained
and so what i often do in
my code is i'll have an explicit
variable
which is bert base encased oops
like this and then i'll just load this
variable into all of my pre-trained
um calls so that then i know that
they're matched
um okay so that's um
sort of let's say standard way of how we
we link these things together
now you're asking how could we
programmatically get from checkpoint to
tokenizer so
let's have a look at what's inside one
of these model files
let's just check that my training is
working
yeah good okay so
in the model we have a config
and
this config let's see
okay so the config tells us uh the name
of the checkpoint
um so
if you wanted to programmatically make
sure that i mean let's suppose
you start with like the config i guess
what you could do
is you could then use this attribute as
the thing that you feed to the tokenizer
so for example i could do tokenizer
equals auto tokenizer from
pre-trained and then i would take my
model i would take my config
and then i would access what is it
is it name
or path
can i access this as an attribute yeah
so i could do this
so i could load my tokenizer this way
and then this would um let's say
guarantee
that the the checkpoints match but to be
honest this is like a bit complicated
so i would more often than not just
recommend
defining a variable with your checkpoint
and then just feeding that variable into
your tokenizer and model
so i hope that answers that question dk
crazydiv
but feel free to ask if it's not clear
okay so um our model is pretty close to
to being done with the training and you
can see that
um uh every um
by default in the trainer every 500
steps
the model will run an evaluation on the
validation set
and log the loss by default so this is
just the training loss
but the thing that sylvan explained in
the video
is that what we really want to do
is compute metrics like accuracy or f1
score or whatever
and so the way you do this in practice
is you define a function called compute
metrics
and this metrics function has to
basically return a dictionary
where you have a key corresponding to
the name of the metric
and then the values that you would
compute from your predictions
and so in this example here
sylvan is leveraging the datasets
library which has
its own metrics as well and then once
you have
loaded the metric for this task in blue
you just have to extract the predictions
and the ground truth labels um and then
you can just do metric dot compute
and this will automatically create this
dictionary
for you which you can then feed into the
trainer
as follows so you can do compute metrics
like this
and then what this will do is that every
500 steps by default
it will then compute the metrics in
addition to the training loss
and this is quite handy because this is
how you can track
the performance of the model on the
validation set as you train and you can
make decisions about okay is it getting
better or
not okay so let's just have a look at
this so
okay so good the model is trained
and you can see that the training loss
here
is around 0.35 we saw
um when we did the evaluation loss it
was uh
roughly double and that was with the
random weights so now if i run
evaluate again i should see
hopefully the loss has gone down
okay it's gone it's gone up that's very
interesting
um i'm not sure why that's the case
um so i'm going to just say that's the
demo gods being mean to me
um generally this should have gone down
unusual might just be a random
fluctuation
in what we've done okay and so just to
sort of
uh dig down a little bit into how we
build this metrics function
the the trainer has a predict method
and you can just feed into that predict
method
data set from datasets and this predicts
method will return an object
called predictions and let's have a look
so this predictions is
a prediction output object it's just
like a data class which has attributes
and the attributes it has
um are predictions so if we look at
predictions
oops that's not going to work
it's just an array of basically all of
the logits from the model
um and we also have the ground truth um
labels listed like as as ids so this is
you know
paraphrase not paraphrase not paraphrase
so forth
so the the main work you often have to
do when you build your compute metrics
function is you need to convert your
logics
into um let's say integers or
label ids because that's the thing that
you want to compare against
and so one way to do that is to just
compute an
arg max which will basically say for
every
prediction in terms of logics find the
index with the
largest or the highest logic and so then
once we apply that
our preds now is a tensor
of integers and then
i can feed those predictions into my
um my metric from data sets and then i
can run
compute on that and it should hopefully
give us these values
so any questions about computing metrics
okay so
um i'm not going to run this last cell
it's just the same thing we did before
it will run the training but instead of
showing the training loss it will show
the validation metrics that we use
but i encourage you to play with this
yourself maybe with
a new data set just to understand how
this is really working
okay so that's the trainer api
this is what i use
let's say 90 percent of the time
it's just very convenient it works and
it means i don't have to think too much
about writing my own
low-level training script or my training
code
which can often be error prone right and
so a good
a good reason to use like high level
apis like the trainer or you know fast
ai or pi
torch lightning or whatever is that they
abstract away a lot of the
the boilerplate code which if you do it
yourself
will probably have mistakes and this has
been kind of battle tested through you
know thousands of users
okay so to wrap up
the session i want to now look at
something that's uh
like really exciting uh for me at least
is um sylvan developed a library called
accelerate
which uh says you know sometimes i
really need to have control
of of the training loop um and
you can do this on you know cpu and gpu
pretty easily there's lots of tutorials
on doing that
but there's been a kind of say trend in
the last few years
towards having access to like multi gpu
or tpu machines and these offer
in principle a lot of speed up because
you can now distribute your training so
you know you can distribute your
your batches to these devices do your
computations
on these devices and then do back
propagation
through the whole um say cluster of
devices
um but in practice it's been very
difficult
to to do this as a beginner and that's
because
you have to understand all this
distributed setup in pi torch or
tensorflow
and again many ways to make errors and
you know
keeping track of how data is basically
parallelized across
nodes is a bit of a pain so this
accelerate library is designed
to make this simple for us and so let's
take a look
at the final video
supercharge your buy dodge training loop
with aginface accelerate
there are multiple setups on which you
can run your training
it could be on cpu gpus tpus
distributed on one machine with several
devices or even several machines
often called nodes with multiple devices
on top of that there are new tricks to
make your training faster
or more efficient like mixed precision
and deep speed
each of the setup or training trick
requires you to change the code of your
training loop in one way or another
and to learn a new api all the setups
are enrolled by the trainer api
and also several third-party libraries
that can help
the problem with those is that they can
feel like a black box
and that it might not be easy to
implement the tweak to the training loop
you need
accelerate has been designed
specifically to let you retain full
control over your training loop
and be as non-intrusive as possible with
just four lines of code to add to your
training loop
we are short of the example of the
training loop video
accelerate will handle all the setups
and training tricks mentioned on the
first slide
it's only one api to learn and master
instead of 10 different ones
more specifically you have to import and
instantiate an accelerator object
that will handle all the necessary code
for your specific setup
then you have to send it the model
optimizer and data loaders you're using
in the prepare method this is the main
method to remember
accelerate controls device placement so
you don't need to put your batch on the
specific device you're using
finally you have to replace the
lost.pack1 line
by accelerate tor.backward loss
and that's all you need
accelerate also handles distributed
evaluation
you can still use the classic evaluation
loop such as the one we saw in the
training loop video
in which case all processes will perform
the full evaluation
to use a distributed evaluation you just
have to adapt your evaluation loop like
this
pass along the evaluation data order to
the accelerator.prepper method
like for training then you can dismiss
the line that places the batch on the
proper device
and just before passing your predictions
on labels to your metric
use accelerator.gather to gather
together the predictions and labels from
each process
a distributed training script has to be
launched several times
on different processes for instance one
per gpu you're using
you can use the pytorch tools to do that
if you're familiar with them
but accelerate also provides an easy api
to configure your setup
and launch your training script in a
terminal
run accelerate config and also the small
questionnaire to generate a
configuration file with all the relevant
information
then you can just run accelerate launch
followed by the path to your training
script
in a notebook you can use the network
launcher function
to launch your training
okay so before we have a look at
low-level training loops in pytorch and
accelerate there's a question
from ebstan who says can i find out how
many labeled samples do we need
to get good results with transfer
learning and fine-tuning
is there a rule of thumb here that's a
really really good question
the at least in my experience the answer
really depends on the task that you're
trying to tackle
so generally speaking and and
you know the the language that you're
dealing with and the domain
so these are all factors to consider um
so
a rough hierarchy at least from my
perspective is that
text classification um is generally one
of the simpler tasks
to tackle with this and in in a sort of
standard text classification context
you may only need maybe a hundred
samples
with transfer learning to get quite good
results
and of course the the thing that you
should always do is build a baseline
so build a really really simple model
not a transformer do something like
naive bayes or logistic regression or
something like this
just as a sanity check that on your
small data set
your your results when they do they
transfer from the training set to the
validation set because there's a really
really good chance of overfitting
here so roughly
a few like 100 to a few hundred samples
for text classification
at least for me has worked well but then
it gets a bit harder as you do different
tasks so
um if you move to say question answering
um
here there's like uh say uh
two strategies you can take um so one
strategy
which is maybe the first one to start
with is
if you're doing question answering or
extractive question answering like squad
is to look for a model that has been
trained
already on squad in your domain ideally
so let's suppose i was doing
a squad in german which is a bit
different to the standard case
maybe i look for squad here and let's
see
i believe there's a german squad and
maybe i can specify the language to
german
okay we don't have that so let's have a
look i believe
there's a company called deepset who
have done this ah it's called quad
okay so here is a german
uh here is a basically a language model
that has been fine-tuned on a german
version of squad and now this lets you
answer
questions um in in german
um so then
i would take this model and if my corpus
is in german
but it's like you know custom maybe it's
my business data
i would then just try to see how this
model works on that data set
now generally you'll find that it it
doesn't perform
as good as the original squad model and
then you would do some say
domain adaptation from the squad model
to your domain
so you basically just do a little bit of
fine-tuning on your domain
and typically you'll then see the model
um
adapts to your to your corpus and you'll
get much better performance
and in that context for say question
answering
typically you need like on the scale of
a few thousand um you know a thousand to
a few thousand examples
to get um at least good results
but you have to be very careful because
um sometimes when you do this domain
adaptation
from one model to another um
if you sort of overfit your domain you
will end up
forgetting all of the good features um
that the
the fine-tuned model had to start with
and so
it's generally tricky in that sense um
and then for other tasks um like named
entity recognition
um this is this is i think very problem
specific
it really depends on the entities what
are the like frequencies of the entities
that you have
and here again i think you're dealing
with on the scale of like
a few thousand examples to get okay
results
so to summarize
um uh okay well just to summarize a
little bit answer the question so to
summarize um we're talking about maybe a
few hundred
examples labeled examples for simple
problems
like text classification to a few
thousand um
for the labeled case and and maybe even
more if you're doing something that's
very niche
i mean if you're doing maybe i'm doing
like um
maybe like legal analysis of legal
contracts
and maybe the domain is is so different
from any existing pre-trained model
that i actually need to do some sort of
um fine-tuning
on on a legal uh corpus that looks like
what i have
and so then you don't need labeled data
per se you just need a lot of unlabeled
legal contracts that you can then
fine-tune a language model
and then transfer to your domain
okay so there's a follow-up question
which says thank you for the answer
what if i have more than a few hundred
of classes for a task
uh okay yes so then that thing gets very
hard um
i would put that in so maybe for text
classification there's like a
a hierarchy of complexity so uh the
simplest case
is like binary classification um and
then
maybe multi-class is after that and then
maybe multi-class
with like you know extreme number of
labels like a hundred or a thousand
different labels
or different categories and then maybe
multi-label is like somewhere around
that
um so i think in general it will
be harder and what what you will find if
you have
a data set which has like 100 classes or
more
is that the model will be very confident
about the majority class
so there's always a distribution
generally in these classes and most of
the time
it's like a power law so you'll have a
few classes that are very common
and then there'll be some that are quite
rare just because you know they're tags
or something that people
don't really use very often so the model
will struggle a lot
in those rare tasks in those rare tags
or those rare labels
and so then what i would recommend you
do is you try to focus on the hard
examples
so you try to collect more data for
those rare examples to boost the signal
for the model so you don't need maybe
like
a hundred more examples of the common
class you need a hundred more examples
of the rare ones
um but in general as long as you can
kind of get like a good coverage
in the labels it should work except it's
just going to be tough because
you know with 100 options the model has
more chances to make mistakes
and in fact there's a very good trick i
should mention
is that when you train a model you can
extract or compute the loss that the
model has on every single sample
and if you do this this will tell you
roughly
which examples um the model is most
confused about and this is actually a
technique
from um fastao well
i don't know if they invented it but um
at least this is where i first saw it
and let's see if we look here at first
ai
um so
i think it's called most confused
let's see
okay so things have changed a bit in v2
okay i can't quite find it but um
basically in the fasta library they have
a function which lets you
plot the most confused examples that the
model is having trouble with
and then with those you can then work
out where you need to collect more data
but roughly speaking what's happening is
it just computes the loss
for every example in your validation set
and then just sorts them and so if you
do that yourself manually
you'll be able to see where you need to
improve the model
okay so let's um wrap up
by diving into the accelerate library
so the difference here is that instead
of using
the gpu we're going to use the tpu
hardware in the back end so we activate
it this way
and we install
transformers and data sets as we always
have
and the the main thing that you need to
do now is you need to install
um some accelerate and some tpu specific
libraries so in order to run pi torch on
a tpu
we need some special
wheels they're called more basically a
binary file that we can install
here and
this will then allow us to run pie torch
on tpu
and the the first thing we do is always
the same it's like we just
tokenize the data so this is pretty
familiar by now
and um one thing that sylvan is doing
here
is he's removing all of the text
columns or the columns that we don't
really want for training
explicitly this is to make it easier so
that the trainer doesn't get confused
when it receives raw text
and he's also renaming the label column
to labels and this just helps the
trainer auto detect
which column it should compute the
metrics on
and the other thing that he's doing is
setting the format of the
elements in the data set to pi torch
tensors
so i'm just going to show you that just
quickly so
if we look at our tokenized
tokenized datasets train oops
if we look at one element um
now what we've seen so far in today's
session
is that everything was just a python
list but you can change the format
of your data set from
lists to tensors
but you can also set them to tensorflow
tenses
if you're running tensorflow or even i
think you can do it for numpy arrays
so it really depends on what you're
operating on that you want to
manipulate but this is a very handy way
of switching the formats
um oops so yeah torch or
torch does it okay um
so um because we're not using the
trainer and we're gonna use our own
training loop
um we need to have what are called data
loaders
so in in pi torch there's a kind of two
concepts
that are important one is like the
concept of a data set so these are the
things that we've been doing
most of the time so far but then when
you want to
feed batches to your model
there's an api called data loader which
will
automatically sample from the data set
and then provide those samples to the
model so you basically feed in
the data set you care about and then you
can feed in whether you want to
randomly shuffle the elements and that's
important for training
just in case you have some you know
ordering in your data that
is artificial you can specify the batch
size and also
how the collation is done for the the
dynamic padding so to speak
okay so you can create a data loader and
then if you look at an element of a data
loader
it's just going to be um basically a set
of tensors associated with
each batch
and then we instantiate our model just
like we
we always have
and
then once this is loaded
we can just do a sanity check that if we
feed
a single batch which just has input ids
attention mask
label and these other ideas i won't talk
about
it returns a tensor which is the loss so
this is like a sanity check that our
model is working and because we're going
low level into the training loop
now we also have to specify the
optimization
algorithm for basically minimizing the
loss function
so i would say the default a very good
default is to use
this modified atom called adam w
and you can just use the the default
learning rate
and you just pass the parameters of your
model that you want to optimize
so just to show you quickly if we have a
look at this
this is a generator so i need to create
a list
and then if i just look at one of these
elements you can see that
the parameters of the model consists of
tensors so these are like our weights
and biases
um along with a name that tells us you
know which layer we're looking at
and so by feeding these to adam we're
basically saying here
is my instructions of weights and biases
i want you to optimize
and then it will proceed when we do the
training to do the optimization
and there's also some extra things we
need to specify like the number of
epochs
uh the number of training steps and the
the scheduler
for how we um want to sort of
control the learning rate during
training so this
if these concepts are kind of the first
time you've seen them um we have
information in the in the course notes
um to help you understand that but
basically speaking
uh using a constant learning rate
throughout training is is sub-optimal
both in terms of speed in terms of um
just getting to
like a good local minimum and so we have
schedulers which will
essentially control how the learning
rate
increases and decreases during training
so we can define the scheduler
did i not define the optimizer
okay so i'm just going to load this
this is just an example when you're
doing things on a gpu you specify the
device
and this is then more or less what a
training loop looks like in pytorch
so you you say
we're going to do training now so we're
going to activate dropout in the model
and then we loop over for every epoch
and every single epoch we're going to
loop over every single batch in the
training data loader and then we're
going to set those
those tenses to the device we care about
we're going to compute the loss and then
we're going to just do
the backward pass in pi touch and then
we just
basically take a step now with the
optimizer and the scheduler and then we
update and this will then just do
training in a normal way on a gpu
or a cpu um but the thing that's uh
kind of cool is that we're using a tpu
so we have in a tpu we have
eight cores on colab and so what we want
to do is we want to basically be able to
do distributed training this way and
there's a nice kind of picture here
of what's going on with distributed
training
where i'll put this in the chat
you can have a bunch of different
machines and each machine has its own
process
so you can think of each process as
being like its own little like
say controller that is processing data
and so what we can do with the tpu is we
can think of it as having eight
different processes
and we need to communicate the the
sharing of weights
essentially how we do back propagation
across these processes
and the accelerate library allows us to
do that very simply
um by basically
uh we define something called an
accelerator
and then we have to prepare
the data loader the evaluation data
loader
and the model using this accelerator api
and this will automatically
work out what hardware i'm running
how many calls i have how should i
distribute the data
how i should you know basically copy the
model
across these um these nodes or these
devices
and then everything else after that is
exactly the same as we saw before
so you don't really have to change
anything in your training script it's
basically untouched
it's just the way you prepare the um
the the training loop so
if you run this it won't work as it
stands what we need to do
is we need to wrap all of the
accelerator code
inside a training function and so if we
do that
we just need to put all this
inside a training function
and one thing i discovered yesterday is
we need to make sure that
the data loaders we use here
um
let's have a quick look
and you are not global variables
let's have a look i think i just do this
okay
so here i'm just initializing a model
i'm initializing the optimizers we did
before and here
the magic of accelerate is basically
going to do all this distributed
placement for us and so it's going to
give us a data loaders a model and an
optimizer
and then everything else runs as normal
and this is where this question about
tokenizing the data is important
so what we've been doing previously is
using dynamic padding so we don't use
padding in the tokenizer directly
and in fact here if you look at when i
tokenized the data
where is it here
in my tokenizing function i just use
truncation
but because we're running on a tpu i
want to activate padding
so i need to put padding equals true
and i'm going to specify the max length
that i want to pad
not to the max length of the full model
because it's too large i'm just going to
specify
kind of arbitrarily that it's 128 tokens
and so once you've um padded all your
inputs
we can then wrap our um
oh yeah we need to then also
re-instantiate
the data loaders here
and now we can
create a training function and
fingers crossed this will then allow us
to
launch a tpu training so
okay so while that's working let's have
a quick look at the questions
[Music]
um
okay so there's a question from i'm
homes there is a hugging face twitch
session today and tomorrow all that was
chapter three
um the main difference is the time zones
so we try to capture people who live
on the sort of east and west of of globe
and there's also a tensorflow session
tonight with matt kerrigan
and so that's for all the tensorflow
aficionados
there's a question from unzonz about
regarding the domain specific cases for
text classification
before i train my model for my
downstream task would it make sense to
pre-fine-tune with
language modeling to better understand
the context yes in general
that's a very good thing to do um it
will
that the amount of boost you'll get in
performance is very dependent on the
domain shift so
if i have bert which was pre-trained on
wikipedia and my text is
kind of like say factual or kind of like
wikipedia
then the boost i get from fine-tuning uh
bert on my corpus won't be so much
but if my corpus is like very different
in domain like maybe it's like source
code or something like this then
then you will see typically a bigger
boost in performance
so it's always worth doing and in
general
it's pretty easy to do there's a
question about
if i want to classify articles instead
of sentences does bert
and friends still work or should i look
at something long former
that's a great question so bert is
basically limited
or most of these sort of vanilla models
are limited to 512 tokens
so if your documents are longer than
that
you'll have to do one of two things use
a model which can process longer
sequences
like long former or big bird from memory
i think they can process 4096 tokens so
they're
much much bigger like eight times bigger
than burt um but if that's not
like sufficient you'll then have to
basically chunk or
kind of split your document into
passages and then you'll have to
feed those passages into the model and
then do some aggregation to work out how
you build up
a kind of representation for the full
document that you can then feed into
your classification head
um there's a question about
to improve the baseline model take a
roberta model
train it yes that's right exactly
im homes asks what is the difference
between using pi torch's default atom w
and the transformers one um that's a
good question
um off the top of my head i don't know
my guess is that there are some i mean
there's a long history of atom and not
being implemented
correctly so
yeah off the top of my head i have a
suspicion that perhaps the transformers
one is
is correct um and the pie touch one
maybe isn't um
but uh maybe do some experiments uh find
out
sorry i don't know that off top ahead
okay cool so those are more or less the
questions let's see something went wrong
and this is now where
i get to do some debugging so let's have
a look
um i got an error and it says
you should probably activate truncation
or padding with padding equals true
to have batched tenses with the same
length
okay so i clearly did something wrong
when i
defined my data loader so let's have a
look
at what went wrong
so i first
tokenized my data
which is good i then need to
set the format ah
i want to get rid of this collate
function this collate function is going
to be the thing that gave us problems
okay so now
i should be able to
launch the tpu training
okay so this is now launching on these
eight tpu cores
and fingers crossed um i didn't make any
mistakes
great thanks for the feedback i am
holmes and dk
crazydiv i'm hoping you're enjoying it
and thanks for the questions um
so this looks like it's training and
yes great oh no we have a problem
okay so
what is it stack expects tensor to be
equal size because 96
okay so um
okay so here i'm going to do some i know
we're running over time so i apologize
um i'm going to see let's see if i can
debug this
um uh fast and if not then
i'll just fix the notebook later okay so
so basically i'm running into an error
and this is a good way of
seeing how tpus are a little bit more
fun than normal it's saying
the stack expects each tensor to be
equal size but i've got 96
at entry 0 and 100 entry one so this is
suggesting to me that somehow i've
screwed up
the tokenization so instead of having
everything
um with the same shape there there's
some um like
something's gone wrong so let's have a
look at
my data loader okay
so
so let's have a look at my tokenization
first so
when i did tokenization i
set padding equals true and max length
and so now
when i look at my tokenized data sets
um let's have a look at
so maybe let's have a look at the input
ids
so the input ids we want these to all be
the same
shape and i'm going to just take
um let's just take say 10 of them
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to say
tensor.size for tensor
in this so let's see what we get
okay so this is telling me that all the
tenses
have the same size which is good
um let's just do a sanity check if i
um go from the end
yep looks good okay
so my tenses are all the same size
and uh should just do this again
and let's see now
what is complaining on about this
invalid type
huh
ah because i need to
return tenses equals
pie torch ah
this is so annoying okay let's not do
that
let's do padding
and then let's remove the column let's
set the format
good okay now let's see what we get
here okay so we can see there's
already a problem
interesting so
cool all right so we're going to try and
do bugs and in fact if someone sees what
i'm doing wrong
this will be great so so here's a
problem the problem is
i've created a data loader um
here train data loader and it's
complaining
that um when i try to put the tensors
together
they're somehow not of the same shape
so let's see what have i done wrong
um
okay so
let's do that so let's um
oops let's look at the first batch and
let's look at um
let's look at the input ids
and then let's look at the size
of each tensor
in here uh-huh
so it seems that my tokenized
data sets are not the ones i was looking
for
so let's have a look what's going on um
if i look at
um so we saw before that these were
meant to be 89
in size um so let's have a look at this
and then we go t dot size or t
in here um
okay so
you can see that in my tokenized data
sets
all the inputs have size 89
but for some reason in the batch
of the training loader everything is 71.
so let's see um
why would that be different why would
the batch be different
[Music]
um
hmm
don't tell me i need this clay function
no that's not what i want because now
they're going to be dynamically powdered
that's an interesting thing i'm gonna
have a look
so let's see if we have
so just just to tell you what i've done
so i've
reintroduced a collate function into the
um
into the data loader here
i was pretty sure we don't want to have
that because we want to have fixed
um sizes um but let's see
if this has um sort of
magically debugged the problem okay
so for reasons i don't understand adding
a collate function
to the data loader seems to have been
important
for letting us do the training and you
can see here
i'm doing on one tpu core
i'm running the training
and what should all these
all these messages write you can see
here if these are the warning messages
you often get when you instantiate a
model
and so what accelerate has done is it's
copied the model
into the eight tpu cores but done so in
a way that the initialization is the
same so we've got the same model at the
start
and then it should instantiate
another seven parallel trainings
so now we're training the model copied
in eight
pieces across eight cores and each core
will get its own batch of data
and then backpropagation will be
synchronized so that when we update the
model
we update based on the losses computed
for every device
um so this is uh
yeah obviously a little bit of a hack
i i i'm a bit um unhappy that it's
everything i said about needing to use
padding um
seems to have been mixed up with the
collate function um
but yeah that's the joy of life coding
um
maybe you can um dive into this uh
yourself and
try to understand exactly um you know
how one is to set this up there's
something i'm still kind of missing in
my head at the moment
but nevertheless that's some let's say
training on a tpu and
one thing that i would recommend you do
as like a homework
problem is try to work through these
training notebooks
on on a new data set and so you can find
many options on the hub so if you go to
data sets
you can look at text classification and
for most of the time this will cover all
the things you have everything you need
now
to to study this um and the other thing
that you can um
do is for example we're doing uh
paraphrase uh detection right we're
checking if two sentences are
paraphrases of another
another uh example of this
would be um the quora data set
and this is this is a very common
problem on things like stack overflow or
quora where you've got people asking
questions and sometimes the questions
are duplicate
and you often rely on the community to
flag questions duplicate or not
and so this would be a nice data set to
use which
would be very similar to what we've done
but give you a kind of different flavor
of dealing with different columns and
different
inputs so i'm going to put that in the
in the chat
as a suggestion and yeah
i would also recommend see if you can
get the tpu training
working i think tpus are a very exciting
development because they offer in
principle eight times as much speed up
in principle but reality is around three
times
um over conventional um say gpu training
and um they're free on collab so now you
can use accelerate to
train faster than normal and do really
cool distributed stuff
all right so that was a bit longer and
sorry for that that's
my fault for not being able to debug my
encode
um so i hope you um enjoyed it and
um tonight there's matt doing tensorflow
if you're into that
and i think tomorrow is then sylvan
doing the next round of this and
next week we're going to be diving into
the sort of more advanced parts of the
library so
what we're going to be doing next week
is how do we share models in the hub how
do we push everything to the hub how do
we share metrics
and so this is going to be the kind of
icing on the cake for everything we're
doing
so i'm not back for chapter four but
omar is and omar is awesome
he's uh he's in the chat right now and
so
you should definitely come i'll be i'll
actually be in the chat so
it'll be like a body swap um
and so i hope i hope you guys see you
then
cool so with that i'm gonna stop
recording and stop the string
so if you have any questions just put
them in the forum and see you next time